I have system curly, Boy Scout Roundtable Commissioner for a hundred an hour head
district in New Jersey, Also assistant scout master of a troop one ninety one,
Bethlehem, New Jersey. This podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, scout master.
So the wife comes home the other day and she says the, the horn in my car isn't working.
So we go outside, start the car, pop the hood. I look a connection is is come undone.
So I fix it and I say: try it now. She hits the horn, The horn now works
And she said: wow, that's something. I didn't know that you could fix things like that.
Well, of course I can. I'm a scout master. Beep Repair, Beep Repair, Beep. Oh man,
Hey, we, there's got to be better jokes out there. Send them in to me, won't you?
This is podcast number two. forty one. Hey,
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look at the mailbag
because it is chock full. this week Art Stanky is in Park Ridge, Illinois, where he works with
troop one, and he said: wrote in to say I've been an email subscriber for some time.
Sometimes I run into scout masters who are more task master than scout master working
with scouts to encourage them to be self-sufficient, make their own decisions.
I've been with our troop for 34 years. Well, good for you, Art.
In the beginning we had a troop where the adults were almost always in the background,
and I continue to get the troop back to the youth led patrol method kind of troop. I remember
A group of older scouts have finally made up their mind to tell the adults to get out of
their way. Well, good for them. I've had the opportunity to work with some of these scouts
and had a long talk with them at camp this summer. I suggested they subscribe to
scoutmastercgcom and learn a few things. Well, I hope that we can help them with that.
Thanks so much for all your help. It may be that some of the scouts will learn more about
scouting and leadership from your work. Thank you so much for your kind words and getting
in touch, art, and we'll do our best to continue to be of assistance.
Rob Glazier is a backer for scoutmastercgcom and he is in troop 18 in Muskego,
Wisconsin. He wrote in to say: I wanted to say I love the new index feature at
Scoutmaster CG. This little sight of yours has become quite a repository and while I'm
not one to criticize it. it was getting a little hard going back finding things I knew
I had seen before. I know you must put a lot of work into the site already, so I
appreciate the enhancements when they come along. This, the index, is very helpful and
if you haven't checked that out yet, folks go to scoutmastercgcom. right there at the top,
in the top menu, you'll see a link to the index and we set that up so that you can find
information that we've published, index by subject, and we're still catching up on
things, still getting everything lined up, but it's it's worth checking out.
Terry Mock is the scoutmaster of troop 226 in Yorktown, Virginia, and he wrote in to say: love
your website and podcast. I have the iphone app and it's not quite working. with my new iphone
6 and iOS 8.1. I like to listen to the blog on my commute
and the apps are convenient way to do that. thanks for all you do. your advice has
helped me time and time again. well, well, take that as a cue to mention two things.
first of all, we do have an app. the scoutmaster cg app is available for all
of you who are in the android tribe as well as the apple tribe. you can have
everything that we produce right there at your fingertips on your mobile device.
you apple folks can find it in the itunes app store
and you android folks can find it on google play.
I will say this: I heard from several of you who have upgraded to the iphone 6
and or iOS 8. there's been a little bit of difficulty getting the app updated for
iOS 8, which, according to what I've heard, is nothing
unusual right now. whenever a new operating system comes out, there's
usually some bugs that go along with that.
hopefully, by the time you hear this podcast,
we will have resolved those difficulties. if we haven't and you're still having a
problem on iOS 8, get in touch with me so I
can tell my app developers about it. andrew west is the committee chair of
troop 5137 in medina ohio and he said: well, you
often speak of jumping into the volcano, but my fellow
scouter, jeff millman, and I have jumped into the super volcano.
we both decided that we could best serve our community
by chartering a brand new Boy Scout troop. troop 5137
is now officially chartered to vfwpost 5137 in medina ohio. the vfw
post has been very helpful in assisting us in getting going well. that is great
news, andrew, it's always great to hear about a new
troop. we had our first meeting this past monday with 12 young but really
enthusiastic scouts. jeff's going to be the scout master. i'll be the committee
chair. we're looking forward to working with both the
scouts and parents on this new scouting adventure.
i've personally gleaned much guidance from your podcast and websites, so please
keep it up well. thanks, andrew, for getting in touch and
sharing that good news with us and for your kind words about the podcast and
the blog. going back to podcast 240, i heard from
james chaplin, who's a scout master, cg backer and also the
committee member of troop 1882 and a round table commissioner,
and he wrote in to say another great podcast. i've been stirring the issue about
how we do boards of review in our troop. you have me on a roll,
reversing my thinking the way i did things in the past.
i always have to remind our adults that advancement is only one of the eight
methods of scouting, or 12.5 percent of what the
scouting program has to offer. james, that's brilliant. i never
really thought of it in percentages, as before,
but that helps put it, put everything in a little bit of perspective and scale,
doesn't it advancement? you know, if you count all the
eight methods of scouting, to be interdependent and to work together
is only 12.5 percent of the scouting program.
excellent thought heard from frank maynard, another scout master, cgcom
backer. he said i nearly drove off the road when i heard
about the white socks in podcast 240.
good answers for a few adults who are getting things
a little back to front about scouting and think they know better.
thanks, frank, for getting in touch. make sure to go check out frank maynard's
bob whites blather blog uh, which is- which is a little tough to say,
but but i'm i muddle through uh. at bob whites blather
frank has got some really great advice, especially if you're involved on the
committee end of things in scouts. so do go and check that out
at scoutmastercgcom. last week one of the posts was about the authority of youth
leadership got a lot of response to it. craig hayward
wrote in and said part of me really wishes we weren't called scout master
and instead we were called something like scout
guider. i think the title adds to the confusion of your role as an adult in
a troop. i'd almost like to give the scout master badge to the senior
patrol leader and give the top adult leader post the
title of advisor or something like that, because that's
really the role you're playing. the title scout master sometimes
can be a little confusing because we're really not the masters or the leaders
of much of anything. we're more advisors, mentors, and i'm
fascinated by the comment that you would exchange the scout master badge for
the senior patrol leader, and i get what you're saying, but
what i'd really really like to see happen is scout masters
to understand that they are not the senior patrol leader. that would be.
that would be a pretty good thing. anthony burgundy wrote in on that post and said
scouting is all about the scouts that run it, and i couldn't agree with you more.
anthony bill poster said i love the line in this post:
scouting is something that the scouts do for themselves, and adults have the
honor of observing, coaching and encouraging. well thanks, bill.
john nelson wrote in and said i wish i could like this more than once on
facebook. well thanks, john. and renais
said i absolutely love this post. so many want to control the outcome of the
meetings and the camping trips and not let failures happen.
well, who hasn't learned from failure? but for some reason, a lot of parents are
very reluctant to let their children fail or make a mistake,
but i think that very thing is one of the greatest moments for learning, and i
certainly agree with you, renais, and thank you for your nice comment.
let's see what else was going on in the blog this week on bp's blog,
a writing that he did about calm and cheery.
that's one that you definitely want to read. here's a quote from it real quick.
the scout master initiates the ambition in the boy,
leaving him free to gain his objective in his own way.
he does not instruct, he leads the boy on to learn from himself.
make sure to check that out. and we also had a post this week which was a
report from a scout master who was one year into the role,
and it's called a new scout master in the volcano. you can find all of this
at scoutmastercgcom. now, if you're a regular reader or
listener and if the information and resources that we share with you
have helped you, you can return the favor by becoming a scout master cgcom
backer. the funds we get from backers go towards the expenses of producing and
publishing all of these resources- the podcast, the blog posts, the videos- and
they're accessible to scouts all over the world.
so you can help. it's easy. just go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link right there on the menu at the top of the page.
you can choose any level of support. some of them entitle you to premiums like
autograph copies of my books. so sign on as backer this week
and i will personally thank you in next week's podcast.
now, over the past couple of podcasts we've been fielding questions and talking
about boards of review, scout master conferences, things like that.
there's a set of comments and and replies that i made to them on last
week's podcast that i want to share with you very before we continue on. in the
comments, john michelle asked: isn't there some gray area between
a scout is tested and a scout is reviewed? and what john's referring to? there are
the four steps in advancement: right, the scout learns, the scout is tested, the
scout is reviewed, the scout is recognized and he's asking:
how do you differentiate between tested and reviewed?
he goes on to say: i do believe a scout is trustworthy. so if somebody has signed
off that a scout has done the necessary requirement, we should all take that
signature at face value and trust that it was completed.
but what if at a scout master conference i'm asking a scout about
an orienteering course that he did to fulfill a requirement, for example-
and i ask him how you like doing it and he says, well,
actually they only talked about that and they really didn't do it. and then
somebody signed the requirement off without really validating anything.
now, should that scout still pass the scout master conference or should i
reschedule the conference? and it is what i'm doing,
retesting? well, john, that's a fair question and i will agree with what you say.
once a requirement is signed, it's done. we've tested,
we're done. now we're in the process of review. so what happens
if during a review, that we discover that something is amiss?
so a scout can't fail a review process. that's not why we're reviewing.
the review may reveal some things that need work, but
we'll talk about that in a moment. let's stick with the specific question that
you posed. the requirement was signed and during the process of review we
discover that now it sounds like somebody just kind of
pencil with this one and the scout really didn't end up
getting the benefit of doing the work to fulfill the requirement.
our next step, after we've completed the scout master conference,
is to talk with whoever signed the requirement. let me ask a question:
is this the scouts fault in any way. how can it be the scouts fault? the
person that signed the requirement has obviously misunderstood their work
and the scout accepted their judgment, and why would he expect them to do
otherwise? so we go to the person who signed the
requirement. we asked them what happened, and let's say it was a patrol leader
or one of the older scouts that signed off that requirement. well, i would ask
him exactly what the scout did to fulfill the
requirement. i'd have him explain it to me, and if he wasn't able to explain
it to me, it would be a really good opportunity right then
to work with that person to help them better understand the advancement process.
it's not my interest to find fault or blame or shame anybody about this.
they've obviously haven't understood something, and so i would take that as
being my failing. i haven't trained them properly. so
we're going to sit down and we're going to give this some discussion so that
they won't repeat that particular mistake, and then i would conclude by
asking if they thought it would be a good idea to go over things with the
scouting question to make sure that he actually has the benefit
of completing the work required rather than just somebody signing the
requirement. so the review process has worked
just as we planned. we discovered a problem and we addressed it,
and it's in no way the scouts fault. it's our fault for not having properly
trained the people who are signing the requirements correct. so,
as you can see, there's no way for a scout to fail
a scout master conference, because it's not a question of failing and passing.
and in the case that you ask about, i don't see any reason to hold the
scout back. he had nothing to do with it. it was not his fault.
now, the other thing you asked, john, is a line of questioning like the one that you
outlined: retesting the scout. well, no, i think that's
perfect. tell me a little bit about the
orienteering course that you went on. tell me what you did there.
did you enjoy doing that? is that something that you really interested in?
you know we're getting to know the scout and we're assessing our program at
the same time. that's part of the reason we have a scout master
conference and it's part of the reason we have boards of review. so we want to,
so we want to direct questions towards their experiences,
to discover how well we're doing serving the scout and to learn a little bit more
about the scout in the process. now tanya
also wrote in and commented on last week's podcast and said: i don't believe
that it's a matter of passing a scout master conference. it it was really pass
or fail here. and yes, tanya, i will agree with you there.
and tanya goes on to say the scout master conference is, however, a tool
to ensure that the scout has completed all the requirements and is ready for
the border review. if a requirement was incorrectly signed off, in my opinion the
scout should be required to complete it before having a border review.
tanya, while i agree that it's not passing or
failing a scout master conference, i'm gonna differ with your definition of
the scout master's conference. it is not a tool to ensure that the scout has
completed all the requirements and is ready for border review,
and that's not really a matter of opinion. that's spelled out very clearly in the
guide to advancement. and here we go: guide to advancement: chapter
numbers: pencils ready. 4.2.3.5. the unit leader or scout
master conference. note that a scout must participate or take part in a
scout master conference. it is not a test requirements. do not say he must pass a
conference, while it makes sense to hold a conference
after other requirements for a rank or met. it is not required
that it be the last step before the border review.
the conference is not a retest to the requirements upon which a scout has
been signed off. it is a forum for discussing topics
such as ambitions and life purpose goals for future achievement
and also for obtaining feedback on the unit's program.
in some cases, work left to be completed and perhaps why it hasn't been completed
may be discussed just as easily as that which is finished.
ultimately, the conference timing in the advancement process is up to the
unit. some leaders hold more than one
conference with individual scouts along the way,
and the scout must be allowed to count any of them towards the requirement.
now, i explained already how it resolved the difficulty, should we find a
requirement hasn't been met. in the questions that,
as the guide to advancement says, are about obtaining feedback on the
unit's program and tanya, you said if a requirement was
incorrectly signed off, in my opinion the scout should be required to complete
it before having a border review. well, i'm going to differ with you again.
again, not a matter of opinion or what i think about the thing. this is
very clearly spelled out in the guide to advancement. nobody
can deny a scout a border review ever for any reason.
and we find that in here we go again. eight point zero, point zero, point two.
boards of review must be granted when requirements are met.
and reading from the guide to advancement, quote: a scout shall not be
denied this opportunity. that's pretty strong wording, right?
a scout shall not be denied a board of review
when he believes he's completed all the requirements for a rank.
who believes the scout believes when he believes he's required?
we completed all the requirements for a rank, including a scout master conference.
a border review must be granted in a case where there is a concern
that the scout has not fulfilled the requirements for rank is written. it is
appropriate to advise the young man that he might not pass the board
and to make suggestions about what he might do to improve his chances for
success. it is, however, the scouts decision to
go ahead with a border review or not. so we've spent quite a bit of time on these
things in the past- couple of podcasts- and i certainly don't mind that. but
let's boil it all down to a couple of things that are easy to remember. so,
principally, we've been dealing with the third step in advancement, the
first one being a scout learns, the second one being a scout, is tested,
the third one being a scout- is reviewed and the fourth,
a scout- is recognized. the review process is not aimed at reviewing the quality
of the scout's work or his grasp of the knowledge or the skills
that he has gained in completing the requirements.
the review process is to make sure that we're all doing our jobs.
the review process has a couple of goals. the most important one that i think
we misapprehend a lot, is that, when it comes to
talking about requirements and the work the scout has done,
what we're trying to do is figure out if we're doing our job,
if we've provided enough opportunity for the scout to get everything
that we've promised him in scouting. the other things that happened during the
review process is establishing a relationship with a scout
where we know a little bit about what he's interested in and
and what kind of a person he is. we're using this as the opportunity to
build that internal standard of the scout, oath and law
and having these discussions with him and very explicitly, as it says in the
guide to advancement, we are not retesting the requirements.
testing is over. we've passed that step. we're into the review part.
now this might run smack right head on into the way things are happening in
your troop. all's i can say is: these aren't
expressions of my opinion. i'm doing my best to represent exactly
what's being said in the guide to advancement 2013.
it's a very important thing for everybody to read and understand,
and it helps clear up all kinds of misunderstandings and difficulties.
so make sure to have a copy and make sure to read it. in the remainder of this
podcast, we are going to chip away at the vast
mountain of email questions that we've been receiving,
and, even though we've had an extended introduction,
it is time to get started. so let's get started. shall we
write me a letter? send it my name
email, that is, folks, and here's an answer to one of your emails.
mike bailey is in shoreview, minnesota, and he works with cup scout pack
9626, and he wrote with this question. my son transferred into a new pack this fall
as a second-year weevilos. the den is preparing to become scouts in
december and all 10 weevilos are on track to complete their era of light.
i'm working with the den leader and it's clear that my co-leader is a little
burned out, and you know what i will say, mike,
in the second year of weevilos. i can understand exactly what you're saying.
it seems like discipline is lacking in the den,
even by a weevilos standard. some weevilos and parents have
kind of let us know that they intend to leave scouting after weevilos. they've
kind of had enough. the troop that we're going to is planning
events from the coming months to entice the boys, but it might be too late for
some. i'm find i'm struggling to find ways to get
across that a larger, better journey is just beginning. without
sounding like i'm preaching at them, and i'm pretty new to this group, so i'm a
little reluctant to step into that role, i would welcome your advice.
well, mike, if the weevilos and their parents are tired out and discouraged from
going any further, it's certainly an indication that something
is off track somewhere, isn't it? you say there is a discipline problem,
and whenever there's a discipline problem in scouting, the first thing i
think is that the scouts are bored, and if they're just going through a list of
achievements rather than doing things that they personally find engaging and
interesting, that might be why they're bored.
has the whole thing turned into dragging them forward rather than trying to
keep up with them? you know, that might be part of the answer.
has anyone asked the weevilos themselves how they feel about all the whole thing?
and that might be a good place to start. and while i appreciate what you're
trying to accomplish, no amount of salesmanship is going to make up for
a program that's a little off the rails. get those weevilos doing things, not
talking about them, not hearing about them, not dragging
them through a bunch of achievements. get them to a troop meeting. get them on a
camping trip. make that the focus of what you're
doing. the guys that really want to have the arrow of light- they're going to get
it anyway. but having the arrow of light and
walking off the bridge into the abyss and not into a scout troop,
that's not going to help anybody. aim yourself at creating the opportunity
for them to get a really good dose of actual active scouting
and see what happens then. now mike's question
makes it necessary for me to drag out the soapbox
and to stand on top of it and to preach for a moment, and this will
probably take about two minutes. so if you want to fast forward,
go right ahead. i wouldn't blame you a bit. but one of our organizational problems
is connecting our independent age-based units with each other,
connecting cub packs to scout troops and scout troops to venture crews and
things like that. i'm convinced if we did that difficulties- like mike
wrote about- would be a lot fewer. scouting's a continuum
of age-appropriate experiences that we unfortunately
artificially interrupt with organizational divisions between cubs,
scouts and venturers. we lose a lot of momentum at those transition points
and it's a real shame because the losers are the scouts.
now, before i go on, i want to say that cub scout leaders have the busiest,
most demanding jobs in our organization and cub scout leaders are usually our
least experienced, least supported volunteers. they rarely get a glimpse
of the rest of the program. if they don't understand
the entire continuum of the scouting program,
it's very, very difficult for them to figure out what their role is and
contextualize the work that they're doing to the rest of the program.
so den leaders and cub masters and their colleagues
have to create and present a massive volume of program elements in comparison
to folks like me who are involved with a scout troop or a venture crew.
over the decades i have had dozens of cub leaders become
assistant scout masters and almost without exception
they all breathe a big sigh of relief when they realize
they don't have to continue to do all this program work
and that the scouts are doing that and that the scouts are leading themselves.
so, from what i've seen, the demands of the program during the cub years
and the work that's usually done by wonderful people who volunteer to be
cub leaders ends up not having any context
of the progressive stages of scouting and this
tends to skew towards bigger and better presentations and programs at the cub
scout level rather than more youth driven
activities. now at the cub scout level, i'm not talking about youth led,
but interest and youth driven activities. most cub leaders are going to be a
few years younger and that means there are probably
going to be a lot more energetic and they pour a lot
into decorating and enhancing their programs.
and now this is all great in theory, but their energy gets spent in an
environment that's basically unaware of the progressive stages that await
their cubs, and things tend to get a little overheated.
so what happens next? well, when cubs and their families are presented with a
real steady diet of big, showy kind of presentation based programs,
they get a little jaded. they end up being spectators and participants in
highly designed experiences rather than being presented with
opportunities to discover and move along at their own pace
and as a result, very little in what they experienced in a cub scout pack
amounts to any practical preparation to be in a boy scout troop.
i know what the intentions are and i know how the program is written
in cub scouts and in weevilos. but i think that there are much
stronger influences that overcome the continuity
that we would like to see develop in cubs and in weevilos.
so during the second year weevilos cubs either grow tired of being dragged
along through things and, as mike shared, they decide they're going to check out
after they have the arrow of light- because you know, i've come this far,
might as well get the arrow of light, but man, then i'm done-
or they join a scout troop without having much of any idea what they're
getting themselves into and we see quite a bit of attrition
during the first few months. the expectations of weevilos parents
have been set by their cub scout experience, that's scouting to them,
and when they get into a scout troop the changes are so big
that they often feel a little frustrated. they feel the adult volunteers in the
troop aren't keeping them informed. they're usually upset when their
sons don't automatically advance like they did in cub scouts.
they find patrol leaders kind of wanting and skill and
not real communicative. they're confused by the idea of youth leadership
and this all leads to a lot of attrition and when i last checked,
we lose four or five weevilos out of ten
in the first year after they've joined a scout troop.
so that kind of attrition means that the alarm bells go off in the troop.
there's a lot of pressure to modify what the troop does to meet the
expectations of the incoming weevilos families
and a lot of times that means that the troop begins looking a lot more like
a cub scout pack than a boy scout troop
and we start basing the program on big presentations and events rather than
opportunities for real learning and growth that are afforded by the patrol system.
youth leadership and those kind of messy, difficult things. right,
and i see this kind of thing in my own troop. i hear it repeated many, many
times in the emails that i receive and i think the root of the problem,
what i first mentioned when i stood up on the soap box here:
we've got an organizational wall between these stages of scouting
and until that wall is breached we're going to see this problem kind of
perpetually repeat itself. so what's the answer? it's a tough
one and it's kind of one of the built-in organizational difficulties that we
have. but cub scout packs, boy scout troops,
venture crews- all ought to be in contact with each other constantly.
venturers should be going to scout meetings and cub meetings.
scouts should be going to cub meetings helping out with dens,
being very involved with the life of the cub scouts.
the more experienced volunteers should be aiding and mentoring cub leaders. now
that's the way that it's set up in a lot of the rest of the world
and i think that we could do a lot of good if we started looking at
how we could lessen the influence of these organizational divides.
that's not a very specific answer, but it's the best i can do right now.
so, moving on, here's another email. one of our assistant scout masters is also
the advisor for our order the arrow lodge. this has resulted in a little
competition between the troop and the oa lodge.
he's encouraging boys to take on leadership roles in the order of the arrow,
where, from my standpoint as a scout master, they've already got a position
of responsibility in their troop. so what i'm experiencing is
a kind of a conflict between the order of the arrow activities
and our troop. what should i do? well, first off, let's not cast the whole
thing in the mold of competition. let's see if we can get all of these
wonderful things cooperating together. we need to get to the point where
both the lodge and the troop can benefit from what the scouts are doing.
in my experience, scouts can handle both their troop responsibilities and the
responsibilities of an order of the arrow
office with a little guidance and a little understanding.
our scouts were vice chief and chief and we had a bunch of guys on the
executive committee for many years and we managed fine. now it's great that
you have the lodge advisor handy as a member of your unit so he's easy to
talk to and i would say something like: i'm
excited. there are so many opportunities for our scouts in the order of the
arrow and you and i should be working pretty closely together to make sure they
get the best of both worlds. if they start getting really involved, we'll
want to watch our schedule conflicts. so where do we begin?
look at it as a cooperative effort, not something where you're in competition.
share the same concerns that you did with me in this email with him.
i want to make sure we're both on the same page. it concerns me a little
bit that we may be setting up a difficult situation for some of the
scouts. let's be sure we're supporting them by
coordinating your expectations for them in the oa lodge and my
expectations for them in the troop. i mean, it's really up to the adults
involved to find common ground and support of the scouts.
if this becomes something where the interest of the troop
or the interest of the lodge or the interest of the lodge advisor or the
troop committee chair or the scout master become the issue,
scouts are going to lose. whenever adults or organizational interests are at
odds with one another, scouts lose. so what we
need to do is work together, with our goal being the best
interests of individual scouts. we need to be flexible and approach it with a
positive attitude and an attitude of cooperation,
and when you do that, the resolutions to these difficulties are going to start
showing themselves pretty quickly. our next email said this.
as a relatively new scout master, my biggest challenge has been getting
our older scouts to participate in, or at least not disrupt, our weekly meetings.
they are mostly starting life scouts and they really don't want to do much
other than sit around and talk. they can get sarcastic and
loud and disruptive, and the senior patrol leader is having a hard time
controlling them. i like these guys and i think they have a lot to offer, but i
haven't been able to get through to them. well, i can certainly sympathize
with you. i've had these guys in the past, so i know exactly what you're
talking about. first of all, as a new scout master, you're the new guy
and they're testing the boundaries, so you're going to have to respond by
showing them where those boundaries are, and you can do this pretty effectively,
and the way that i would suggest you do it is a not talk to them as a group. start
having, uh, little informal conferences with them,
one at a time, and in those little conferences, ask some questions.
the reason i say don't try and talk to them as a group
is because you're outnumbered and they're smarter than you.
the secret laws of adolescence kick in and a lot of the adolescent world is
very uncool to have a straight on conversation with an adult
and be seen to be doing that by your friends. so talk to them one at a time,
and here's what i would ask them. i would say: so listen, tell me what are your
plans in scouting? do you intend to become an ego scout.
what kind of an active contribution are you making right now to your troop? do you
think the way that you're doing things, in the way that you and your friends are
behaving, is maybe contributing to what's going on,
or is it taking away from what's going on? and how are we going to work
together to sort all of this out? see what they have to say, get them to
think this through- and you've said that you like these guys and you think that
they have a whole lot to offer, and that indicates that they're probably
actually pretty good guys. they're just not really aware of what they're doing.
so if you sit down and you appeal to their sense of duty and their sense of
honor, and you do that on an individual basis to begin with,
you're going to get some good answers and some strategies to help resolve the
situation, and then, if they act up after that,
you have their own ideas and thoughts to turn into a question,
and that should help them figure out exactly what's going on.
you've talked with several of the guys and they've resolved to be more helpful
and not to be disruptive. you get to the next meeting and
they're just doing the same thing over and over again.
that's where you can talk to the group. that's fine.
hey guys, you told me yourself that you consider the sort of behavior that
you're participating in right now to be distracting and difficult.
so can we stop doing this and start doing those great things that you
suggested you could do to be supportive and remember,
if they're just hanging around and they have lots of time to sit and talk, that
means that they don't have anything to do.
so make sure that they have plenty to do and a lot of this will start to go away.
it's always going to drive you a little bit crazy.
it's just the nature of the age, and you should pat yourself on the back that
they have this great place where they can come at least once a week and
they can get together and talk. but i understand your frustration and
hopefully the advice that i've given you will help you sort through it a
little bit. if you need some advice, or you need a little help,
or you just want an understanding area, you can get in touch with me and you're
going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
hey, thanks for listening to this 241st edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch. go to scoutmastercgcom and you can read all
the blog posts and see all the other podcasts there,
and while you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates by email.
you can get the scoutmastercg app on google play or the itunes app store
and keep everything that we create right there. it's your fingertips on your
mobile device. you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
you can join the 6700 folks who like scoutmaster blog on facebook,
tweet along with the course of over a thousand tweeters on twitter,
pin the pultritudinous pictures, profit publicly with 1700 other prolific
pinners on pinterest watches at youtube, or join the
400 odd folks who form the exclusive scoutmastercg circle
on google plus. i know that many of you can't face facebook and twitter
makes you better. you have no interest in pinterest, you don't put the? u in
youtube and you're a minus when it comes to google
plus. well, that's all right. just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email. that's right. you can get in touch with me,
clark green, with your comments and questions at clark
at scoutmastercgcom. c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom.
did you know? the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts of America didn't know that.
hmm, they're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America either,
or any other scouting organization for that matter. i'm sure they have much
better things to do with their time. now it's really just me talking into a
microphone trying to lend a hand to scoutleaders,
and i do have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of that, here's
our founder, sir robert bedan. pal, sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping. well, thank you, sir,
until next time everyone.